[Music]
cannabis consumption lounges are one
step closer now to opening public
workshop was held today to go over all
the regulations joe mohler was there
he's live just outside the grant sawyer
building with exactly what happened
today what'd they decide on joe
before anyone can apply for a license to
open a consumption lounge the compliance
board must finish all the regulations
for that industry while today they went
over this draft of the regulations at a
workshop and the public was able to come
in ask questions and raise their
concerns
from cannabis serving sizes and
packaging requirements to training for
employees tuesday's workshop covered it
all questions and concerns came up about
the application process and the social
equity licenses
right now 10 licenses will be awarded
for private standalone lounges 10 for
social equity applicants to increase
diversity in the industry and then
unlimited for dispensaries looking to
add lounges aisha goings is the founder
of the cannabis equity and inclusion
committee i'm eager for the state to
move forward but i also want it done
right
i appreciate the slow roll because this
way we're not going back and saying we
should have did this and we should do
that mainly local dispensary
representatives and future applicants
went over suggested language changes on
the current draft next the board will
consider those changes
just a few moments ago i spoke to the
executive director of the board who says
they do expect that after today they
will have one more workshop to go over
some smaller changes that may happen the
one thing many people want to know is
when could we see one of the lounges
opening up here in southern nevada he
expects by fall reporting live near
downtown las vegas joe muller live local
now